je ne me souviens pas d'avoir autant du
des clients enfin des patients plus
exactement cliniques privées sortir de
là scandalisé en dix ans on a essayé de
me rationné la nourriture les soins le
personnel etc ça n'est pas le cas dans
les cliniques privées on sait qu'il peut
y avoir
des manques par rapport au service
public justement mais on sait aussi
qu'il ya un service il ya il ya dix
mètres carrés il ya un confort qui
n'existent pas toujours dans le dans les
services publics là visiblement celle
inverse donc on peut se priver quand
même la question vous pensiez vous plaît
oui mais ce qui est terrible c'est que
pour pallier à ce manque dans le dans le
service public on est en train de
privatiser le service public c'est à
dire que vous fait hospitaliser dentelle
chu et c est vous êtes accueillis dans
l'entrée même du chu vous êtes
accueillis par une entreprise privée qui
vient
prendre dit différents renseignements
sur vous pour savoir si finalement vous
allez accéder à une chambre seul ou pas
et si vous aurez le téléphone ou pas et
combien vous allez le payer et combien
qu'est ce que c'est que ce cirque eux la
enfin non l'hôpital public devrait
rester publique et bien les pales
devrait rester ehpad tous les jours ou
presque je reçois sur ma boîte mail d d
invitation à investir dans l'ehpad voilà
fait un placement dans l'épave mais
demain je ferai l'objet d'un placement
dans l'ehpad ça suffit ces histoires
c'est effrayant non je veux pas aller
faire de placement en ehpad mais demain
je ne veux pas que l'on me places en
ehpad je demande en revanche à un ehpad
de m'accueillir éventuellement parce que
je serais peut-être très content d'en
trouver un je demande d'y être accueilli
certainement pas placé
[Musique]